está acusado de extorsión en banda
organizada y participación en una
asociación delictiva con vista a
preparar un delito el hermano de la
estrella del fútbol habría intentado
chantajear a Paul Pogba para recibir
grandes sumas de dinero en varias
ocasiones en agosto publicó un vídeo en
tiktok anunciando que se preparaba para
hacer declaraciones perjudiciales sobre
Paul estoy haciendo esta vida Hoy estoy
embarcando en este proceso es porque
creo que el público francés italiano e
inglés así como la afición de mi hermano
y más aún la selección francesa la
Juventus los compañeros de mi hermano y
sus patrocinadores merecen saber si
estas cosas cuatro amigos de infancia de
Paul están también acusados de los
mismos cargos por la justicia francesa
además de secuestro en banda organizada
el hecho que alertó a las autoridades
ocurrió en marzo cuando Paul estaba en
la su ciudad natal unos hombres
encapuchados y armados encerraron al
futbolista en un piso exigiéndole 13
millones de euros y secuestrándole hasta
las 4 de la madrugada por ese hecho Paul
va a transfirió 100.000 euros a uno de
los acusados marchas Pogba y los otros
señalados niegan las acusaciones y
aseguran que han actuado bajo la presión
de un grupo del que murieron detalles
en este caso mi cliente también es una
víctima del chantajista y está Atrapado
en un procedimiento que va más allá de
él con individuos que han utilizado su
proximidad con Paul Pogba para intentar
hacer esta extorsión de fondos
hasta ahora Paul Pogba no ha reaccionado
al caso actualmente el futbolista
francés tiene una lesión de rodilla y su
participación en la Copa del Mundo de
Qatar todavía no ha sido